38 % les français ne sont que 38 % à
considérer la télévision comme source
d'information fiable
c'est le plus bas niveau depuis que la
confiance envers les médias est mesurée
depuis 1987
elle arrive et un derrière la radio et
la presse écrite entre la télé et ses
adeptes à travers le temps il y a eu des
hauts et des bas au plus haut niveau en
65% des français jugent et la télévision
crédible mais dès les années 90 les
choses se trouble à racheter
j'ai confiance en personne l'exemple
parfait de la défiance envers la télé
remonte à 1991 avec la fausse interview
de fidel castro sur tf1 les images du
président cubain proviennent d'une
conférence de presse mais les questions
ont été enregistrés à posteriori
qu'est ce que vous diriez à la
télévision française pour essayer de
défendre ce régime face à la méfiance du
public la profession s'interroge sur les
plateaux télé je pense que nous sommes
passés d'une époque où il y avait un
certain joue politique c'est à dire qu'
il n'était pas très simple de travailler
librement
ça me passer à une époque de joux
économique il ya des chaînes
commerciales il ya des chaînes publiques
mais tout cela est peut-être un peu trop
réguler par le marché par la notion
d'audience par la recherche peut-être de
l'émotion à tout prix la défiance est
telle que la question d'une loi pour
encadrer la déontologie journalistique
se pose
le conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
même s'il réguler les pratiques de la
télé y est opposée je crois qu'il y a
quand même des exemples qui doivent
donner à réfléchir que sans souhaiter
déréglementation des lois nouvelles
les journalistes d'ailleurs d'abord dans
une école on les forme
ensuite on les perfectionne et puis dans
la vie de tous les jours et bien sache
que la responsabilité très lourde
mais la défiance du public envers la
télévision n'est pas forcément à voir
d'un mauvais oeil
c'est en tout cas l'avis de daniel
wolton du cnrs sur le peu de confiance
que le public à l'égard des médias c'est
une bonne chose pour les journalistes
parce que ça leur fait prendre une chose
conscience d'une chose évidente c'est
que le public est plus distant plus
critique c'est prendre ses distances et
n'est pas dupe du jeu de la
communication
depuis 2003 les français accordent plus
de crédit à la radio et à la presse
écrite
jusqu à ce qu internet arrive et
devienne la plus grande source de
suspicion dans le même temps le
numérique a bouleversé notre rapport aux
images sur le net comme à la télé tout
son team au je crois un peu d'issues qui
fait que plus le nombre d'image augmente
plus sans doute on leur donne
l'information plus les sources sont
différentes
et puis ils ont peut-être ce sentiment à
mon avis évidemment à justifier qu'on
peut un peu et manipuler enfin la tnt a
débarqué le nombre de chaînes gratuites
est passé à 26 dont celle d'information
en continu
l'info accéléré instantanée et parfois
décrié tout en étant très demandé par
les téléspectateurs
[Musique]